but he's still there
[Music]
okay
now how do i get this
all right now i don't know if anybody's
still there
anybody still there
what are you 10 30. i doubt it
no
so there's no one there
all right yeah so there doesn't seem to
be anyone here now so what do we do just
forget about it
um
i'm trying to find your live stream here
yeah it says one
person
um
what i'll do i'm just trying to find the
live stream it's public right yeah
yeah and what was the title called
i think stream or something
streak or streak or something like that
um i mean i can do it anyway even if
it's not live and it goes up on youtube
yeah i
mean you can just have it live uh right
now if you would like and then it will
automatically afterwards put it on
youtube okay there's no way you can
alert the people who showed up have we
have any record of who actually tried to
show up
i'm going to uh find your video okay
and then i will message the people on
the forums and whatnot
and i'll send them their link your link
so i'm just gonna have to look for your
video right now which way or you mean
the one we're doing right now correct
okay
okay
all right okay okay bye bye
all right so here we go um
we had a bit of an event
uh this morning um first of all i was
able to set up instagram so i started
live on instagram
and and then i found that my the stream
on youtube wasn't working now part of it
is because youtube has changed how they
do things
and so i would send a link to get on to
um
to the event
but unbeknownst to me i was in safari
and it doesn't work in safari so
we were trying all kinds of different
things and we couldn't figure out why
it wouldn't go live
so now i realize i have to do it in
chrome
so i'm starting again so i'm going to go
over even though
i don't think there's anybody out there
live but this will go up
after the event
and uh what i wanted to talk about was
the importance of variety
and uh since you know we're in this sort
of streak 90-day streak we want to be
focused for 90 days and and really
achieve our at least a significant
improvement uh whatever our level either
we're starting in a language or we're uh
you know well along and we want to
because very often at that later stage
we don't feel we're making any progress
we want to
kind of take us take ourselves to the
next level
and one of the things that i think is
very important in that regard is to to
vary what we're doing wherever however
much variety you can introduce the more
variety the better in fact i don't need
the glasses now since we're not fighting
the computer um so for example in my
croatian
i have focused on my mini stories and
i've listened to them 20 30 times uh
which is very good because i'm actually
for just having been at it for a little
over a week i feel quite good about my
uh croatian i understand the many
stories serb operation i think the
stories are in serbian we're also
getting them in croatia i understand
it's almost the same language
but i also did get
when i was in montreal i picked up this
croatian or i can't remember where i
bought it but
so i'm going through that as well
and you never know what leads to what so
in there there was a mention of a
blog
blogging site in croatia blog.hr so i
went there and there's some blogs which
i can import into link and study
i also have this audiobook of the bridge
on the drena
and the ebook which i imported into link
and that's more difficult the blog
articles are easier
then i mentioned that on twitter and
someone said here's uh
croatian radio where they have
audio files for download so i downloaded
a couple of audio files and i put them
on my happy scribe
automatic transcription service that i'm
subscribed to so now i have those texts
that i can study some are more difficult
some are easier
it keeps things varied and interesting
and if you're going to stay on something
where you want to work at it every day
you have to vary it vary the content
vary the activities
have a discussion with a tutor
just to keep things varied if you like
doing anki
go for it i don't but i do review
my saved links for example uh
you know as i go through my many stories
for those of you who are joining late
here we had problems because i was in
chrome and i should have been at least i
was in safari and i should have been in
chrome
anyway
uh
so uh as i have read the same mini story
two three four times
when you then go and read it again you
know i try to sort of save different
phrases and i try to make it interesting
but inevitably if you're going over
something again and again
the brain is less and less interested
so i typically what i do is i go in and
i go through the flash cards the link
flash cards if i go into a story and
they say story number 25
and i see it's got 12 saved links then
i'll go through this 12 saved links
first and then i'll read the story again
so it again introduces an element of
variety
um
you know
difficult material easy material
different books different sources all of
these things keep it interesting for you
keep it interesting for the brain
expose you to
you know the same content essentially i
even went on uh
you know amazon and bought the ebook
version of a teach yourself croatian
just the text no audio
uh something i'm going to read it's on
my kindle i can read it
on the
on the plane
i don't think i'm going to bother
importing it into link because it's
relatively easy and at this point i know
a lot of those words but it's just
another
way of bringing essentially the same
content content in exposing my brain to
a lot of the same stuff but in a
different way and a different format
and all of that is good for the brain
the more you vary things the better uh
if you
try to nail you know i'm gonna nail uh
1000 most frequent words or i'm going to
nail this it's it's less and less
effective every time you do that so i
just wanted to emphasize the importance
of a variety and
and of course you know i
have to admit that every language i
learn i do spend a few hundred dollars
on it uh it might be in the form of uh
starter books it might be in the form of
an e-book it might be in the form of
lessons on italki or on link
uh my subscription service where if i
download some audio files i i get them
transcribed
works better in some languages than
others it worked quite well in turkish
it was not so good in arabic
it's a problem because i would love to
have
these uh you know al jazeera and the fat
cat
podcast properly transcribed because i i
need that material now to take me beyond
i can't keep on doing the same stuff
the same easy material you've got you
know i can vary some easy material in
there but i want to push myself to
difficult material so i just want to
stress that
you know
varying variety is the spice of life i i
was on instagram while we were
struggling to get on here on youtube i
was on instagram and i mentioned
something that i was told you know i
guess
back in 1974
when i left the government service and i
went to work for uh this large canadian
lumber exporting company i had a boss
and he used to have all these sort of
cryptical sayings and one of his sayings
was it's a long road that has no curves
and we can't all wonder like what does
he actually mean
and
he would say this whenever we had
problems
and
this was along with another saying he
had was which was because we were a
lumber exporting consortium we had
member sawmills and we had our customers
and of course the customers would
complain about delivery quality whatever
and the mills would complain that the
customers were unreasonable or that
we were unreasonable or
that we always supported the customer we
didn't support them when there was a
claim and whatever they always complain
so we would always be kind of hit by the
customer and hit by the supplier
and so he would say you know this this
would be a great job if we didn't have
customers and didn't have suppliers well
yeah in other words our job is to
somehow
resolve these conflicts between the
customers and the suppliers and
similarly he says he would he used to
say it's a long road that has no curves
so if you're walking along a straight
road and it's just straight the whole
time it's tough to stand it gets boring
whereas if there are curves and it goes
up and comes down and there's some
variety then you don't have that
impression of it being a long road
or as long a road and the same is true
in language learning you have to keep it
interested interesting and you know i
often mention uh manfred spitzer the
german neuroscientist who points out
that the brain needs novelty
repetition yes in order to get these
neurons firing but also novelty to keep
it fresh to keep it interesting
and if you vary the content then there
will be a lot of repetition necessarily
of some of the same words and phrases
but in a new context in a different
context and all of that keeps it fresh
and interesting and novel for your brain
and you learn more so you have to look
at ways to vary not only the content but
the activities talking writing anki
flash cards whatever read again
and uh so uh these are the ways you are
it's going to be more effective on your
streak or stream
or 90 day challenge now for whatever
reason
i am not seeing any questions i don't
know if we have questions or i haven't
turned it on or or what the deal is here
uh
so
and maybe we don't have any questions i
don't know
you know all this technology
yeah it is a bit of a challenge
getting too old for it
um but i don't see any
questions
so i don't know if uh eric is watching
this
if he can tell me why we don't have any
questions because typically we do
so um
live chat
participants
no
in stream well i don't see any questions
so i'm just going to end it i apologize
for
the uh just on the chance that there are
some
questions but i don't see them let me
just ask go to slack
back in here
um
i'm just gonna say i don't see any
questions is the chat on
let's see what he has to say
uh happy to answer questions but i don't
see any questions so
maybe i can get some instructions here
on how to see questions
is the chat on the answer is yes okay
that's not very helpful why
don't i see
[Music]
questions
and do you see any
questions
he's typing he types slowly
um
wait see
i see them from my end as a viewer okay
that being the case
uh well
send me some
i didn't bring you know in the past i've
had my
my
ipad here and saw the questions there
but of course that's again in safari
what's he saying
okay do you think it's possible to
surpass a native speaker
no
oh let's be clear
yes
it is possible for a language learner to
use the language better than a native
speaker
richer vocabulary more grammatically
correct and so forth because there are
native speakers who develop habits which
are
what they hear around them but which are
not quote to be politically correct
standard usage but in fact
are not grammatically correct
also uh if you have a a non-native
speaker
who reads a lot
only two questions
why is it taking so long to send me
questions
who reads a lot and acquires a lot of
vocabulary
and also it helps too that
if you have a clear mind you're going to
use languages more clearly even not your
own language so i have definitely i
often tell the story i had a swiss
banker came in to see me with
his british sidekick
and the swiss bank is spoke like a swiss
and he used english better than his
british sidekick like he the swiss with
the swish accent was clearer and more
precise and used better vocabulary than
his british sidekick so yeah it's easier
okay what do you find strangest thing in
the romanian language
so every language is strange in the
sense that it's different from what
we're used to
one of the things that's interesting in
romanian which is also the case in greek
and in serbian although not always in
croatian
is the sort of uh what i call the you
know if you say i uh
i um
i want to speak okay so in english and
in most of the other languages i've
learned these european languages
the um the second verb is in the
infinitive
but in romanian they say vrausavarbesque
so the second one is it's i want i speak
and uh
fellow namilao
in greek they say the same thing i want
i speak
and uh
um
that's i forgot now jeremiah
so that's something that seems to happen
in these balkan languages that their
form
is to have them in the same person
interesting
other than that strange things no there
were sort of vestiges of of cases there
i have a question about adding link by
reading harder content but reading
harder content make me feel painful so
what should i do with my life
you have to vary it it is painful to
read more difficult content
uh ideally we find some intermediate
content
and uh so we're looking at that you know
what constitutes intermediate content
blogs
can be i spoke to uh
a french blogger and another english
blogger the podcaster rather and they
put out
dialogues monologues
and whenever speaking naturally like now
i am going to use more high frequency
words
so that makes it easier than say
literature uh
in the case of uh croatian
the uh blog material that i imported
from this one site
uh is easier than the book by evo
undridge so it's it's kind of ideally we
find that intermediate content that's
interesting and not too difficult
otherwise we kind of fight the hard
stuff and then we go back to the easy
stuff and we find it easier again so it
is quite good to go back and forth
is there any relation between memory and
language learning well yeah there's a
relationship
obviously because we remember things
but the process by which we remember is
not a ma it's not a matter of deliberate
memorization at least how i do it i make
no effort to memorize anything i just
find that and never mind that i listen
to these stories like the croatian
ministers 20 30 40 times and each time i
try to notice different things and then
i notice the same words and phrases in
other content that i'm listening to
because i like to vary it and so by this
frequent exposure certain things start
to stick and certain structures start to
stick but it's not because i
deliberately try to memorize them so to
that extent yes memory matters but i'd
say the relationship is between memory
and language learning but not
memorization and language learning and i
think we all are capable of
memorizing or learning words in our own
language simply through enough exposure
and therefore i think we are all capable
of doing the same in another language
i started studying chinese and i'd like
to know if i watch a lot of shows and
read books that are not in link a lot
with it to help i mean obviously the
more exposure you have to comprehensible
content
uh
the better you're gonna do it doesn't
make any sense to listen to things you
don't understand or to read things you
don't understand
but
you don't have to be in link if you're
reading a book pick up a book any book
you know take a book whatever it might
be what do you know the fall of
yugoslavia the third balkan war misha
glenny what do you know quite a
coincidence i grabbed one book but
uh yeah read expose yourself talk meet
people all these things
uh are going to help
how often do you use your chinese not
very often we have
one couple here friends that we know and
if we see them once a month i would use
my chinese that's about it
we did go on a trip with them we visited
crete with them so obviously we were
traveling with them so for
five six days we saw them every day but
otherwise i don't really use my uh
chinese let's see very much
let's see what else we got
what do you talk about with your tutor
do you plan or write questions do you
have a general topic each time
okay
i have no plan with the tutor we don't
know what we're going to talk about
the good tutors get you talking
uh typically you know in the case of
turkish i would talk about the turkish
dramas that we were watching on netflix
and we would talk about how that's not
necessarily representative of life in
turkey
uh i would talk about how i want to
visit turkey we might talk about food
my tutor might ask me what did you do
over the weekend what do you have for
breakfast
for dinner
what sports do you like it's really the
tutor's responsibility to keep you
talking
and then if i have something of interest
that i want to talk about i bring it up
and
certainly write don't write down any
questions we don't have a general topic
nothing
one thing i did in persian because
i was
you know at such an early stage and
having so much trouble reading
uh
and i did it too in arabic because
reading in those languages is a problem
is that we read online because it's not
obvious in arabic and persian just how
you pronounce the words i wouldn't do
that say in croatian i don't have an
online tutor for croatia but even in
turkish i wouldn't do it because turkish
is essentially pronounced the way you
see it there's some things that the e
becomes ah some things that are a little
different but
uh
essentially uh
yeah
i did that have those deliberate like i
would actually i started persian i
started going in with the mini stories i
would read some of the mini stories and
then my tutor would ask me questions
about the mini stories because i was was
at such a low level
that
i had to at least have the mini story
something that i had been listening to
so that i would have some vocabulary and
so she would ask me questions about the
mini stories so that was to get me
started but that was only for the first
few sessions and thereafter it became
general discussions turkish we started
into general discussions
obviously very limited at first and then
it got better
uh what do you think about learning
lines by listening and reading harry
potter of course you have to be
interested but i'm asking is a book
translated in many languages
of course anything that you read
and listen to is good
harry potter is a tremendous i have
never read harry potter but harry potter
is great because it exists in so many
languages just like le pt pass
um
you know and and if people know the
story it makes it familiar for them
and i think that's really great if
you're familiar with the content
um
you know it's easier to learn the
language because
it's well known that
more than vocabulary is being familiar
with the content that helps you
understand
and i even find that listening to my
mini stories which i know in other
languages i don't have to focus i know
the meaning so i'm now seeing the words
that that describe what i'm already
aware of in the story and so i already
have that level of understanding and it
helps so
certainly
uh
harry potter but that would be a little
difficult but it would be an excellent
way an excellent way
do you think that learning with link
brings more breadth than depth
depth means speaking and breadth is only
understanding written
no
this is from abdulmajid no
my feeling is that
you have to get the language into you
and tell you the language is in you you
have very little you can say and you
can't understand what the other person
is saying so
the
when we say learning with link we're
talking about input-based learning
input-based learning is preparing you
for
eventually being able to speak now at
some point you have to speak
you can speak to a tutor at link you can
speak to a tutor at italki you can speak
to your friend it doesn't matter but you
have to build up that potential in the
language you can't just start by
speaking now
i find now with the many stories i'm
able to start speaking earlier
and introducing speaking once or twice a
week introduces an again an element of
variety in my learning
a because i'm trying to find the things
that i've
you know introduced to my brain and also
because
with the tutors report
i now get new
content to study and and it's it's
around vocabulary that i tried to use so
i review those i listen to my tutor's
voice reading the words and phrases and
i have a full list of the last three
months six months nine months of my
discussions with my tutor as a course so
the
talking to the tutor is a great thing to
do
i'm much keener on starting earlier than
i used to be because
i found that i have increased my
comprehension and my ability to produce
the language through the use of the many
stories
but um
so no i don't think that at this point
about breadth or death i don't agree
any recommendations for in chinese
literature i mean it depends entirely on
what you're interested in in my case
perhaps because when i was studying
chinese in
1968
69 of course there was a cultural
revolution in china and anything that
came out of china was 100 propaganda and
wasn't very interesting and therefore i
found that the chinese literature and of
course chinese literature prior to the
20th century is too difficult because
it's written in wenya and it's written
in this sort of literary chinese so my i
was very interested in the literature of
the 20s and the 30s in china uh you know
lot of young for example uh lausa or
lusin or people like that uh but it all
depends on what you're interested in
uh i guess that's it
um
any more
no
uh
all right oh he's talking how many words
should i read to be fluent in the
language
uh
it depends now this person who's asking
the question
has read over 4 000 words according to
link
that's not very much
uh
let me just have a look here i'm gonna
go into my link account
and let's just see here
and uh
okay let's go here
i think and if i go to my
uh
profile
and
if i look at
so if i look at russian
and i go uh words of reading
and i go all time
uh oh you know what i shouldn't look at
it here i should look at it here because
you don't start to see
uh it says oh here we are
yeah i mean russian here
all time
um words of reading
1.3 million
words of reading
in russian
uh and uh i think i'm a b2 in russian
if i go to
let's say
check
uh
1.5 million words of reading
now in russian i've read more away from
the computer if i go to turkish
i have read 182 000 words and i've only
been at it for three months
so
400 000 is not a lot
i think it ha and that of course that's
just the way we measured it like you may
have read more elsewhere but
um
so 400 000 is not a lot but to be fluent
you also have to speak so you eventually
have to speak
so it seems emotional in the languages
that you're able to immerse yourself in
by living in the country of course
of course
um
[Music]
now i i you know i'm not
bad in spanish i'm not bad and say
swedish
i was on television and russian and
ukrainian
uh
but i haven't lived in those countries
uh i haven't lived in a country where
they speak mandarin i lived in hong kong
and in those days they didn't speak
hardly any mandarin
so i'm quite fluent but
english french japanese are my best
languages and i lived in the countries
where those languages are spoken the
more you speak
and if you have good comprehension and
good vocabulary and you've done a lot of
input based activities then obviously
that makes you speak better
i'm quite confident that if i were to
spend a month or two in the czech
republic
my check would be very good
but i don't have that but i have a lot
of potential a lot of known words
but if i was there and meeting with
people regularly and watching tv and
reading and stuff yeah of course i would
get better so it's it's but i don't
think you can go to the country in the
hope that you're automatically
going to become fluent just because
you're there
i i constantly stress the fact that
there's
all kinds of things you can do to build
yourself up
uh before you go to the language of the
country so that you can benefit from it
so like i
learned the chinese that i have i
learned it in hong kong
essentially nobody other than the odd
shandong restaurant and my teachers
nobody spoke mandarin
now if i were to go and live in beijing
for six months my mandarin would
certainly improve
uh if i go and live again in japan my
japanese will improve uh
if i lived in russia
uh
then uh perhaps my russian no perhaps my
russian would certainly improve
but there's so much you can do on your
own before you go to your country
uh what are your takes on learning
russian and ukrainian at the same time
or would you suggest doing russian first
second how long did it take you to be
fluent in russian okay
so i mean i speak russian with mistakes
russian took me a long time
it was my first slavic language
um
even ukrainian took longer than but we
didn't have the ministers i'm just such
a fan of the many stories uh now like
croatian is i'm up to speed in no time
much faster than what's the case in
ukrainian
um
i would like i kind of changed my mind
depending on my experience
right now i'm going three months three
months
uh
i would say
[Music]
that if i were starting from scratch i
would focus on russian
uh because that's like your first slavic
language just don't confuse yourself
with different case endings
in some cases right or i i would stay on
russian for
i mean
the languages are quite close 60 similar
in vocabulary and very similar in
in grammar and of course they both use a
cyrillic alphabet
i would stay on russian and then at some
point
i would go into maybe go a year of
russian and then go
three months six months of ukrainian and
then you can go three months on three
months off between the two of them
but i would uh
i would experiment
uh what do you think about luca
lamporiello's translation technique
you know luca is a phenomenal polyglot
uh
one of the best
and he speaks so many languages so well
so his system works for him and i would
imagine it would work for
most learners one of the things is that
you have to want to do that
so i don't i'm not motivated to do that
uh
okay and i should explain luca
lamporiello's translation technique as i
remember it is that he translates from
the language he's learning into his own
language and then he translates
from
his own language back into the language
he's learning so he does a lot of
translating
that's work
i like to do things that are easy so i
just start the day by listening
and then i do my reading and linking and
that's about it the next day i do the
same and i just let the language come in
and some stuff sticks some stuff sticks
early some stuff sticks late and that's
all i do because it's easy
uh but if i were more deliberate perhaps
i would do something like luca does i
did on occasion you know you can use
your our uh the dictation
function
at link to you hear something you gotta
type it out uh i have thought that we
should add to our flashcards
the uh
sort of a a
translation feature so that you would
say read the um a phrase in english
which is the translation of a phrase say
the target language let's say it's
croatian you would get you would save
that phrase you'd get an english
phrase that you would have to make sure
was accurate and then you would go
through your flash cards
in the english translation of these
phrases and you would have to type the
translation so
this is something i would like to
introduce for those people who like to
do it i am sure it works it's just a
matter of what you are willing to do
uh it's good to write for example i'm
just not disciplined enough to write
much in the language um
but it
gets back to the theme of variety i'm
sure it's a good thing to do having not
done it personally i can't really vouch
for it tell us about the history of link
and how did this business idea come to
you it wasn't so much of a business idea
at first
i've told the story before we
actually it started when i was learning
cantonese
i found out about this chinese immigrant
to canada who had all his money stolen
at the airport so he said because we
were building software for sawmills he
was an i.t guy
we'll give him a job to help him out
and if he's good he stays if not at
least we helped him out uh he
had trouble communicating in english
theoretically he knew english you know
had a high score in toefl but he
couldn't really communicate and so we
developed something along the lines of
link to help him
also because i was aware because i have
so many books here in spanish and german
and there are always words that i didn't
know and
i looked them up and i forget them and
so
i said let's do something like this
and
he eventually went back to china
but um
we then tried to interest the
immigration department here and
immigration department and everything
connected to them is just a bureaucratic
mess
with a lot of protecting the sort of
immigrant service
societies that feed off the government
so in the end we made it into a
multi-language platform
and i think we were driven more by our
interest in the project rather than
it as a business idea
and we just stayed with it for a long
long time
and it's been a long road
and
but we are totally committed to it it's
been so much fun for me
and
as a result of link uh in the last uh
12 13 years i've learned
well when i wrote my book i was at nine
languages i'm now with croatian it'll be
22. so what's that 13 languages in 13
years so it's been great
uh how do you find the time to spend
with a language especially for busy
people well everybody is busy but
everybody has other activities
so the advantage with language learning
is that you can combine it with other
activities i can listen while doing the
dishes listen while in the car listen
while working out
and then i and of course while listening
there's things i don't understand and
then i just have to find another half
hour or so to read and to create links
and so forth and then i go back to
listening the next day off into the same
stuff or to new stuff
so it's not hard to fit in an hour and a
half a day if you're motivated
um
yeah
there is time it's a matter of how you
do it
okay
i'll just see
is that it
that's it okay we're gonna call it here
i apologize for the confusion initially
uh didn't know that i had to be in
chrome i didn't even realize i was in
safari
but we eventually ended up having a
discussion here so thank you and uh i'm
off to croatia tomorrow
so i won't be doing these for the next
couple of weeks because i don't know
what the status is over there but i will
stay on my croatian
servo croatian street and i hope you all
do too bye for now